the west las vegas arts center has an  incredible new addition  the queen of art sculptures were  unveiled in a special ceremony a little  earlier today  this is a 15-foot tall structure  celebrating african-american culture  and it was created by renowned  international artist  gus and lena ocamposilba now the works  of art were selected by west las vegas  community members it was back in 2016  in order to grace the entrance there of  the arts center  finally seeing the product of their  labor go up today and seeing the  community's reaction to it and how much  they love it is just really  it's what public art is all about really  thrilled  completion of the project was made  possible by 40 thousand dollar  donation from the hughes corporation to  the mayor's fund for las vegas life  the program aims to support more  innovative programs like this that  improve the quality of life for all las  vegas with a special focus on vulnerable  populations